hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge sims
hier mir wurden in den letzten folgen
wiederholen glaublich viele kommentare
geschrieben was ich mache ich bin
übrigens gerade total fertig weil ich
gerade aufgestanden denn ihr
zugeschrieben macht dies macht das macht
man hier dass der ein bisschen kochen
kann
das sollten wir auch echt mal lernen was
allerdings auch sehr oft geschrieben
wurde war macht ihr noch einen
mitbewohner und ich habe jetzt
er kennt der haushalt besteht jetzt aus
lucka der da vorne der enkel luca rom
das doch mal weg die kacke ich habe
einen neuen mitbewohner gemacht ich
würde sagen den wecken wir als auch mal
eben die erste begegnung von luca und
seinem neuen mitbewohner jedoch nicht
wer unterhält sich lieber mit bob als
mit uns luca buch was was tust du hast
einen neuen weg falls ihr euch fragt wie
dieser neue mitbewohner hier ist das ist
max
ihr wohnt jetzt auch noch mag wir haben
halt so übels viele geschrieben einfach
galas lukas schwul werden mit max und
sonnenschein und da wird bei den spielen
habe ich gedacht es geht das überhaupt
maxis gerade wütend und wir versuchen
jetzt gerade aufzumuntern
ich habe mal musik gemacht im turnverein
ich weiß es hat gar nicht passt aber die
hat nur kaká sondern habe ich gedacht
ich kann auch singen dazu hätte ich auch
nicht gezeigt die auch die staubsaugen
längsten sorgen dass das sieht man immer
noch und auch unter der kommode also
dass das war super viel spaß aber immer
noch unter der kommune ist immer noch
ganz ganz viel schmutz denn max nicht in
einer wg wohnen würden
luca ist beschämend was soll das denn
lukas max zu beruhigen und manche teams
solltet ihr noch stehen wird ein gebiet
richten baby mein gesicht erstmal wachst
du auch alpakas so gern wie ich mag auch
ihr sollt schwul werden alter türen
wieder negativ was ist denn das für eine
scheiße was tust du luca ist total
traurig und max total wütend auf alles
hat gepasst er setzt sich mitten in der
nacht um 4 uhr an einem jetzt bringt der
da auf der bank deren luca das schön
schläft hab ich jetzt einfach mal kurz
zu maxi gewechselt er echt extrem wütend
ist weil wir ihn aufgedeckt haben weg
niemals einen faulen sims auf das ist
nicht wahr
da steht er gerade auf und fuhr zwar
erstmal gelassen hätten vermutlich
lieber eine tolle rum blödelei morgen
zwischen max aber da ich hab den müll
grad schon rausgebracht und du musst es
nicht mehr machen marx ist das nicht
toll und sie ist heute so schön aus
obwohl ucatis aufgewachsen bist wollen
wir heute mal zusammen let's play auf
dem ich glaube dass dafür am mittwoch 10
uhr auf den soffin
das ist der 28 das kann man super machen
kann geht das auf handys
da kann man die anschließer am computer
dann können wir danach zusammen schlafen
gehen ich habe schon gestoppt sorgt als
du den müll rausgebracht hat und dann
habe ich uns beiden schon kameramodell
apropos da hinten steht auch noch ein
café herum ja ich kann gegenüber max
andeuten meine mutter sei ein lama bei
dem spiel wundert mich tatsächlich
nichts mehr führten nach einem
unerfreulichen gespräch und er ist auch
drei stunden wüten was ist das denn für
eine scheiße ich habe gedacht diesen
direkt hier so die übelsten groß und
werden die besten freunde aber dann blut
tut mir leid bob du hast eigentlich
nichts getan typischer haushalt in der
maus wg luca sitzt auf dem bett und
trinkt und max
max wacht jetzt jeden moment auf laut
der leistung dann werden wir mit max
einfach mal wieder versuchen mit luca
ein wenig zucker da geht er einfach weg
wachs hat seine charisma fähigkeit
verbessert und macht nun häufiger
erfolgreiche witze die max jetzt schon
wieder ein plus bekommen max zielgerade
irgendwas von leider vergaß und wie viel
geld er mich in münchen die jost ag
würden super erzählt von sich selbst
das passt ich würde gern mit max
zusammen joggen gehen aber ich habe max
als faulen charakter eingestellt
deswegen weiß ich nicht was das auch ich
bin ja sogar gerade als max mein geld
sehe ich da aber egal wer wegfliegen wir
hier direkt vor der tür steht aber an
klauseln alex und max ist am handy und
wählen was mit drachen oder so lukas
steht darum und diese ist lugano
rangieren die beiden sich dauernd jetzt
noch über alles möglich weiter
unterhalten würde ich sagen das war's
mir diesen part vom sims wenn es euch
gefallen hatte ich die idee gefällt dass
ich max gemacht habe und weder das geld
wäre natürlich wenn jetzt merge oder so
wir haben noch gar keins merger alles
klar wer daran eigentlich interessiert
dass max und ich vielleicht mal
irgendwann zusammen sondern design
rausbringen und dann also auch nur
limitiert jetzt nicht dass wir immer und
nicht so kommerziell sondern einfach nur
mal ein mal gucken wie bei euch ankommen
schallt ihr das mal bitte in die
kommentare sonst würd ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und weitere sachen die
ich machen soll auch in die kommentare
und dadurch nehmen wir uns irgendwann
wieder ciao